o que é a interdependência
se você for olhar o significado dessa
palavra no dicionário da língua
portuguesa
vocês vão ver que interdependência é
relação de dependência entre uma coisa e
outra estadual condição dos indivíduos
estarem ligados conectados por uma
relação de dependência mútua dependência
recíproca
afinal de contas nós somos
interdependentes
nós seres humanos eu acredito que somos
mas eu acredito também que nós estamos
esquecendo disso nós estamos negando
essa condição tão intrínseca da nossa
espécie
isso me faz lembrar uma história onde eu
pude ver isso na prática começou
exatamente há 15 anos atrás quando eu
tinha concluído mestrado em ecologia e
estava em busca de emprego eu fui
selecionado para participar de um
projeto no lugar muito especial que eu
não conhecia até então que é o parque
nacional do pantanal matogrossense bem
no meio do pantanal bem no coração do
pantanal quase na divisa com a bolívia
vocês podem imaginar a alegria eo
entusiasmo de um jovem colo de 26 anos
de trabalhar numa área tão remota e tão
selvagem como essa eu fiquei muito
entusiasmado e partir para essa aventura
o trabalho é uma parceria da une que me
contratou com obama é para desenvolver o
plano de manejo daquela área é o
documento que estabelece as diretrizes e
ações para a preservação daquela área
o trabalho durou um ano e nesse um ano
eu passei vários meses morando lá
naquele local na sede do parque
completamente imerso naquele ambiente e
ali eu pude ter o privilégio e
oportunidade de conhecer melhor o
pantanal e principalmente conhecer
melhor os pantaneiros e viver o dia a
dia deles
infelizmente eu fiz várias amizades
dentre as quais uma muito especial foi
com o seu benjamin um velho pantaneiro
que eram guarda parte ele sozinho
patrulhava mais de 100 mil hectares
sozinho
ele era um líder comunitário é muito
respeitado na região
ele defende aquela área com unhas e
dentes como se fosse o quintal da sua
própria casa o que de fato era
e também me lembro muito de ter tido a
oportunidade de aprender com os
cientistas os especialistas que fizeram
esse estudo e onde eu pude então
aprender muito mais sobre animais e
plantas do pantanal pode interagir de
perto com a biodiversidade do pantanal
eo aprendizado que eu trouxe nesse um
ano foi o seguinte o pantanal é água e
água é pantanal
ponto final a água é o elemento que
mantêm a vida naquele lugar
o pantanal depende da água a água vem
das nascentes dos rios que estão a
quilômetros de distância lá no planalto
no cerrado
e essa água vem com as chuvas e enche o
pantanal todos os anos e nunca faltará
uma área plana e baixa pagar o pato
atualmente é quando para de chover vem
estação seca o pantanal começa a
esvaziar começa a secar ea descobrir que
esse vaivém das águas formam um processo
chamado o curso natural de inundação é
como se fosse um coração pulsando em
cheia do pantanal de água esvaziando de
água como se fosse um coração que mantêm
a vida ali
nesse processo ele é tão rico que
animais e plantas e o próprio homem
pantaneiro está acostumado com isso eles
têm o ciclo de vida
sincronizados com esse processo os
peixes por exemplo assim como é que o
pantanal começa a encher
eles começam assim federa na calha
principal do rio
preparando-se para migrar para as
cabeceiras onde eles vão colocar seus
ovos
esse fenômeno é conhecido como piracema
depois esses ovos e larvas
eles descem de volta para a planície
pantaneira e encontra uma infinidade de
ambientes aquáticos como lagoas baías
meandros uma abundância de alimentos
onde eles vão poder crescer e se
desenvolver
quando o pantanal começa a secar
entre maio e setembro os peixes começam
a voltar pra casa do rio
só que alguns muitos deles ficam presos
nas lagoas que já tão rasas tornando se
presa fácil para milhares e milhares de
aves que chegam para se alimentar
nesse imenso banquete natural e as
condições para as aves são tão
favoráveis que muitas espécies
aproveitam essa mamata resolvem se
reproduzir ficar por lá constroem seus
ninhos ali é muito bonito ver essas
espécies algumas espécies constroem seus
ninhos nas árvores em colônias chamados
ninhais é muito interessante você passar
perto de mim ao escutar aquela algazarra
de milhões de aves nem todas
empoleirados ali formando verdadeiros
flocos de algodão de neve é uma beleza
tão grande que atrai turistas muitos vêm
de países distantes pra ver esse
espetáculo da natureza
são mais de 300 mil turistas por ano que
visitam essa área interessados na nossa
natureza
isso gera emprego e renda para o povo
pantaneiro sem falar da pesca uma
economia muito importante o pantaneiro
vai pescar para comer para alimentar sua
família
mas ele também vende o peixe para fazer
um dinheirinho uma renda com isso sempre
que também tem o pedro pescador
esportivo que visitam o pantanal todos
os anos é tanta riqueza que alguns
pesquisadores da embrapa pantanal
resolveram calcular essa riqueza
então esses pesquisadores decidiram um é
calcular os serviços ambientais do
pantanal como por exemplo o peixe tem
uma fonte de proteína é importante que
aquelas pessoas potencial turístico de
recriação potencial de geração de
energia e por aí vai
eles chegaram a 112 bilhões de dólares
por ano enquanto pantanal vale e eles
fizeram outro cálculo bom se a gente
treinar o pantanal como fizeram lá no
pantanal no meio oeste dos estados
unidos e plantar soja e colocar pasto
quanto será que gera de renda isso eles
chegaram à conclusão de que o valor
cairia para cá 414 milhões de dólares
por ano
ou seja quase dez vezes menos
o resumo dessa pesquisa foi o pantanal e
vale mais preservado do que convertia em
áreas produtivas e toda essa riqueza
repito é por causa da água e os
pantaneiros sabem disso ele tem uma
relação de respeito com a água
jesus não há água e respeito à água
se estão com fome eles vão bem ali pegar
um papo pra mostrar como a gente vai
comprar um pão na padaria da esquina
as crianças e os cachorros ficam longe
da margem do rio
porque nós e bobi ao jacaré um pouco
atrevido pode vir em abocanhar eles têm
uma relação de respeito com água e sem
falar também do transporte
todos eles usam canoas e barcos e se
você não sabe pilotar no pantanal você
nem ninguém
você vira motivo de piada até as
crianças lançada sua cara e eu tive que
aprender a pilotar o barco então para
começar foi respeitado lá pelas
pantaneiras e eu lembro que ficava horas
e horas contemplando aquela correnteza
silenciosa do rio
escutamos vários sons das aves e vendo
aquele colorido das piúva floridas e 200
de serys e alvorecer os mais lindos que
eu já vi na minha vida
cada dia com uma cor diferente pareciam
pinturas artísticas e eu percebi o
quanto que aquilo tudo fazia sentido
junto quanto aquilo tudo é
interdependente e eu estava conectado
com aquilo
de alguma forma eu falei sobre
interdependência no começo ingraçado que
na ciência também se fala sobre isso
quando estava na minha graduação na
faculdade de biologia
eu comecei a ler vários livros de
autores famosos da área ambiental
em um dos livros que eu lembro que me
chamou muita atenção foi desse autor
chamado james lovelock esse naturalista
britânico que escreveu um livro na
década de 70 que causou muita polêmica
muita controvérsia no meio científico na
época esse livro se chama teoria de gaia
porque foi tão polêmico com essa teoria
porque essa teoria dizia que gaia o
planeta terra é um superorganismo vivo
como se fosse uma célula um corpo e tudo
que existe dentro dessas ela descobre
está interconectado num em perfeita
harmonia e equilíbrio portanto homem
planta rios mares rochas minerais tudo
tudo está interconectado um grande
organismo vivo que a gente viu mais cedo
que este organismo está ficando doente
seriamente doente por conta dos efeitos
do aquecimento global que causa às
mudanças climáticas
a gente viu mais cedo que o prejuízo
financeiro que isso causa e o relatório
da níkolas externo
o cientista britânico de 2007 diz que 20
por cento do pib tendo perdido por conta
dos efeitos devastadores das mudanças
climáticas e mais de 300 mil pessoas
morrem todos os anos segundo o relatório
anatomia de uma crise silenciosa do kofi
annan e secretário das nações unidas de
2010 esse relatório
bom aí lovelock não perdeu a chance e
ele não perdeu a oportunidade já
velhinho com mais de 90 anos ele
escreveu uma série de livros chamado a
vingança de gaia onde ele diz olha esse
organismo vivo está doente está tão
doente que chegou um ponto já é
irreversível e que muitas espécies vão
desaparecer inclusive a nossa espécie
humana
ele foi bastante catastrófico mas ele
foi muito coerente com o que ele estava
dizendo há 40 anos atrás ninguém
respeita ninguém viu mais recentemente
eu comecei a freqüentar um templo
budista e me converter ao budismo e
estudando o budismo
eu cheguei à conclusão de que os
ensinamentos de buda estava muito
alinhados com o que eu estava lendo na
minha pesquisa em ecologia na minha
pesquisa ambiental e muito alinhado com
os valores com os quais eu levanto todos
os dias da cana vou trabalhar
eu aprendi que buda se iluminou porque
atingiu um estágio é de transcendência
espiritual e física
ele teve muitos aprendizados nisso
muitos insights e ele passou a
compartilhar isso através
lamento as escrituras um dos principais
ensinamentos dele há 2.500 anos atrás
foi que nós somos interdependentes todos
nós dependemos uns dos outros e nós
coexistimos e se nós coexistimos nós
dependemos uns dos outros
há 2.500 anos atrás alguém falou sobre
isso é incrível porque a água é um
elemento integrador por natureza a água
integra tudo essa mesma água que nós
conhecemos hoje é a mesma água de
bilhões e bilhões de anos que nós entre
ancestrais conheceram a mesma água aqui
de novo os dinossauros conheceram
será que a gente tem uma relação pouco
mesquinha e utilitarista com água
só que eles não considera a importância
disso para era se era geológica do
planeta
a gente acaba se apropriando da água
para satisfazer nossas necessidades
a gente não conhece a gente não respeita
a gente não admira a água tem que passar
a conhecer respeitar e admirar para
estabelecer uma nova relação com o meio
ambiente principalmente nas cidades não
é pessoal
hoje mais de 80% das pessoas no brasil
moram em cidades
se você pegar o senso de 1980 era muito
mais pessoas vivem na zona rural da
cidade está perdendo essa conexão das
coisas
na cidade a gente conhece a água da
torneira para frente da torneira para
trás
nós não conhecemos tem um lado bom da
crise está em são paulo
nós passamos então a saber pelo menos da
onde vem a água que abastece nossas
casas em são paulo
quem mora em são paulo certamente já
sabe pela imprensa ou deveria saber o
ponto eu quero chegar aqui com vocês é
que a gente não conhece algo nós não
valorizamos nós não admiramos
quero fazer uma menção aqui ao pantanal
novamente
a pesquisa que a ong wwf e produziu
junto com o ibope em 2012
era uma pesquisa de opinião
funcional para saber o nível de
conhecimento dos brasileiros sobre o
pantanal o que o brasileiro pensa sobre
o pantanal
nessa pesquisa me chamou atenção 22
aspectos dela primeiro
mais de 90% dos entrevistados nesta
pesquisa disseram que já ouviram falar
do pantanal
ok eu conheço já ouvi falar e aí quando
o entrevistador falou tudo bem já que
conhece a ponta no mapa pra mim o mec
fica o pantanal dois terços das pessoas
apontaram os locais errados
apenas um terço dos entrevistados
apontaram o local certo
ou seja a gente não conhece o nosso
próprio patrimônio
aliás as pessoas acham que o pantanal é
fica na região norte a maioria na
amazônia
portanto se a gente não conhece a gente
não valoriza toda vez que vocês forem
abre agora a torneira na casa de vocês
o chuveiro da casa fechem os olhos por
alguns segundos que seja e tenta
imaginar os ecossistemas aquáticos que
estão por trás daquela turnê daquele
fevereiro com processos interdependentes
autônomo seguindo a ordem natural das
coisas
imaginem quando vocês foram os da água
enquanto que as espécies e as pessoas no
pantanal estão lá dependendo daquilo
pulso de inundação
imaginem a teoria de gaia do james
lovelock dizendo que a terra era um
grande organismo vivo que está doente
imagine buda dizendo que isso era mais
independentes e precisamos respeitar as
coisas e principalmente procurem
experimentar algo que lhes tira da zona
de conforto e que evite situações como
essa a gente está vendo essa fotografia
afinal de contas todos nós somos
interdependentes e essa é a nossa
natureza
obrigado